just in an unexpected end to uh this
game it almost didn't even start this
one what was your reaction when you
first saw this move G6 and after that H4
H5 at this point you knew that you had
something you knew that maybe this
bishop takes G6 was working what was
your reaction
I don't know I mean after age five
like I thought it was
the first I started it was not should
not be working but
basically
after rotate E2 change AC to Queen a
warehouse cleaning Force
I think so then
so then maybe then I started like
thinking maybe it doesn't work maybe it
might be the best move but because I was
also thinking about different positions
such as Bishop E3 but
then I guess black plays F5 and
lose the night yeah to f-8 F6 and
I'm not sure it looks what was going on
through your mind except the chess moves
like at this point he knew kind of that
you were almost winning you you needed
that you need this Victory also the
tournament hasn't been going that much
your way right uh you needed this
Victory what was going on through Europe
no no I mean I was not thinking about
like exactly matsun game I'm just trying
to play
playing like natural moves as some
weights and not not having obvious not
allow any obvious drive but
I was not thinking about like muscle
game or anything but I mean after H5
like I've probably seen this line
like I looked at this type of line after
each word Maybe
like
probably like many years ago a while
back yeah yeah and then I I have never
seen like this 85 Bishop takes G6 thing
and it was like I do not like if I know
H5 was a move I'd probably see the trick
after Bishop G6 but I just do not
remember that I also
I've never seen yeah so I mean that's
why maybe it's Bishop takes G6 here but
great reaction pinpoint accuracy after
that to finish the game you almost have
a second rest day uh in this tournament
how are you going to use it are you
going to relax a little bit get ready
for the next game what's the plan I
don't know probably just
I mean maybe you're trying to improve
with the openings and in general and
maybe
I guess
yeah probably mostly just improving
improving the opening and then prepares
starting to prepare for the next
opponents but
well Justin congratulations uh great day
at the office for you we'll see you
tomorrow okay thank you our
congratulations as well just